I need to have characters in my brain
and I need characters
that are coming together so I I need to
actively be working on someone so I'm
working on a character Amber right now
during the day I can have things that
irritate me but I have the problem
solving of how will Amber get out of
this situation who what is Amber what
else does what else does she need what
does she want to say to the world so
it's it's maybe it's a way to avoid the
the conflict happening around me where I
can kind of almost meditate on this
character that I'm working on and this
you know that I may that this character
actually kind of don't like but as I'm
writing her I'm writing her completely
out of love and